in this lesson we'll discuss nitro
enolates nitro compounds similar to
carbonyls can be deprotonated and they
can undergo alkylation reactions and a
reaction similar to the aldol let's look
at alkylations first suppose we have a
nitro compound with this structure we
can treat this with base and the base is
going to be able to deprotonate this
acidic proton and these electrons are
going to have resonance stabilization
with the nitro group this forms an
intermediate that looks like this and
now we can treat this with an alkyl
halide now the electrons can push back
down through the conjugated system
attacking here and displacing bromine
now nitro compounds might not be super
useful and maybe natural product
synthesis few natural products actually
contain the nitro group but plenty of
them contain amines and a quick
reduction step will allow us to access
these compounds the nitro compounds can
also be used to produce carbonyl
compounds treatment with an oxidant in a
base for example these conditions here
allows us to access a ketone in this
case because we have an R group over
here if R is H these same conditions
give us an aldehyde now let's look at
the Nitro analogue of the aldol reaction
this reaction is called the nitro aldo
or the henry reaction for this reaction
will start with nitro methane I'm going
to add in the proton that we want to
deprotonate and it's useful to mention
here that we can use even mild amine
basis to promote this reaction because
the resonance of the resultant enolate
with the Nitro is so good so we can use
something like triethylamine to
facilitate this deprotonation and in
this case I'm going to skip showing all
this resonance to the group and just put
the anion on the carbon that's going to
do the attacking
so just like with a carbonyl compound we
can show the deprotonation facilitating
the formation of a double bond in this
resonance form or we can show the
deprotonation putting an anion on carbon
now we'll treat this with an aldehyde or
ketone here I'm going to use an aldehyde
because it'll allow me to show you a few
subsequent reactions and what we can
make from these compounds we have this
carb anion here it can attack the
electro positive carbon of the carbonyl
pushing the electrons up onto oxygen
this attack plus a protonation step
gives us this nitro aldol product now we
can react this product in a variety of
ways to produce really interesting
compounds like before we can reduce this
and the Nitro aldol product will afford
us amino alcohols oxidation with chromic
acid without a base present will oxidize
just this alcohol right here if we
protect this alcohol here we can then
use these conditions to oxidize our
nitro to the aldehyde deprotection of
this compound will reveal an aldehyde in
an alcohol in a 1:2 relationship now the
Nitro aldol produces an alcohol with the
aldol we can promote dehydration pretty
readily just by perhaps warming our
reaction under equilibrating conditions
but in this case we can still decide
rate it just requires a second step here
are some example conditions for
dehydration and this produces a nitro
alkene this nitro alkyne can be
converted to an aldehyde under these
conditions but the nitro alkyne itself
is also very useful in synthesis this is
an electron poor Diana file so it's a
great partner for the diels-alder
reaction when heated with this
relatively electron rich dyeing the
diels-alder reaction can proceed giving
us a cyclohexene the enol a of a nitro
compound is distinct from the enol a of
an aldehyde or a ketone this is because
the
ion forms on the carbon that's attached
to the group and and not one carbon away
so when we're looking at products like
this and perhaps thinking how we can use
alkylation of a nitro enolate to do this
our disconnection is going to be
adjacent to the functional group and so
if we want to think about this example
retrosynthetic lee our positive Centon
comes from the right hand side of this
disconnection here and our negative sin
thon is the equivalent of this so this
type of reaction actually represents a
polarity reversal of an aldehyde or
ketone we usually expect the carbonyl
carbon to be attacked but the Nitro the
nitro enolate is the synthetic
equivalent of having an anion on that
carbon opening up new unique reactivity